>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, BREAKING
JUST MOMENTS AGO FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES BILL BARR HAS
EXPRESSED DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
IG'S FINDINGS SURROUNDING THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE.
THAT WAS NOT HIS ORIGINAL
MANDATE.
THAT IS THE MANDATE OF JOHN
DURHAM.
NOW IF TRUE, IT LOOKS LIKE,
WELL, THIS EXPLAINS A LOT.
DOESN'T IT?
HERE FOR REACTION, THE HUGE
DEVELOPMENT
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WE EXPECT, ALL RIGHT, YOU BROKE
IT HERE ON THE SHOW ONE WEEK
FROM TODAY WE WILL GET THE IG
REPORT ON FISA ABUSE.
DURHAM WAS APPOINTED AS I
UNDERSTOOD FOR THE ORIGINS OF
THE RUSSIA PROBE.
BUT ALSO THAT IS NOW OFFICIALLY
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
EXPANDING ALSO INTO FISA ABUSE
AND OTHER ISSUES.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS NOW
POWER TO CONVENE A GRAND JURY,
HAS NO POWER, FOR EXAMPLE, HE
POINTED OUT McCABE AND COMEY
LACKED CANDOR, SO NOTHING
HAPPENED AS A RESULT OF THAT.
BUT IS IT NOT INCONTROVERTIBLE
THAT THERE WERE MULTIPLE
WARNINGS TO THE FBI AND DOJ NOT
TO USE THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER,
THAT IT WAS UNVERIFIABLE, AND
THAT THERE WAS A BIAS OF
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, AND A MEMO
CALLED THE GRASS GRAHAM MEMO,
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOR
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOT
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOO
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOE
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOV
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOR
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOF
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOC
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOT
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOO
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOS
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOW
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOT
SAYS THE BULK OF INFORMATION FOE
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER.
ISN'T THAT AN ESTABLISHED FACT
IN THE CASE?
>> I BELIEVE IT TO BE SO, BUT
HORWITZ, WE WILL SEE WHAT HE
SAYS.
BUT THE FIRST THING I WANT TO
SAY IS BE WARY OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
ON WHAT IS COMING UP WITH
HORWITZ.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING OVER TIME
TO SPIN THIS THING TO DIMINISH
THE EFFECT, TO DOWNPLAY IT.
I CAN TELL YOU WITHOUT ANY
HESITATION,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR HAS EVERY
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORLD IN
MR. HORWITZ.
HE BELIEVES THAT HE HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB.
A PROFESSIONAL JOB, AND HE
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFF
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFR
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFT
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFH
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFE
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFS
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFP
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFT
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFI
APPRECIATES THE WORK AND THE EFO
DISCLOSING ABUSE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF ABUSE.
IN DECEMBER 2017, McCABE
TESTIFIED IN THE HOUSE,
ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE AND TELL
MEMO THAT WITHOUT THE
STEELE DOSSIER, THERE WILL BE NO
WARRANT ISSUED.
SO WHAT I WILL ASK MR. HORWITZ,
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THERE WOULD
BE NO WARRANT, WHERE THEY WERE
LIABLE TO THE STATE, DID THEY
KNOW THAT STEELE HAD A BIAS?
DID THEY IGNORE IT?
WHEN DID THEY GET THE WARRANT,
BEFORE OR AFTER?
AND HERE'S WHAT WE WILL FIND
THAT THEY PULLED A FAST ONE ON
THE FISA COURT, MISLED AND
DEFRAUDED THE FISA COURT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU WILL
FIND.
>> Sean: OKAY, SO YOU WILL
HAVE HIM IN YOUR COMMITTEE ONE
WEEK FROM WEDNESDAY.
WE GET THE REPORT A WEEK FROM
TONIGHT.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
I THINK SOME OF THIS WOULD
EXPLAIN THAT THE DELAYED ASPECTS
OF ALL OF THIS, ONE.
BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD CLEARLY THAT
THE FACTS ARE DEVASTATING.
AS HE LAYS OUT THE FACT.
HE MAY NOT MAKE THE CONCLUSION,
BUT THAT WOULD NOT BE AS PER
VIEW ANYWAY.
>> NUMBER ONE I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT HE WILL BE FAIR
TO EVERYBODY.
THE PEOPLE INVESTIGATED, THE
PUBLIC, THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
ALL OF US.
BUT HERE IS THE POINT, NO
WARRANT WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THE
QUESTION FOR ME AND EVERYBODY
ELSE IS HOW RELIABLE IS THE
DOSSIER?
DID THEY KNOW THAT IT WAS
UNRELIABLE?
WHEN DID THEY FIRST TRIED TO
VERIFY IT?
BEFORE THE WARRANT OR AFTER THE
WARRANT?
WHERE THEY WARNED THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS OUT TO
GET TRUMP?
DID THEY IGNORE THOSE WARNINGS?
OF ALL OF THAT PROVED TO BE
TRUE, IT IS DEVASTATING.
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
CONCERNED.
AND THE FISA COURT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND IF THEY ACCEPT THIS AS OKAY
BEHAVIOR, THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD
GET RID OF THE FISA COURT.
>> Sean: OKAY, AGREED.
BY THE WAY, I WOULD HATE TO SEE
THAT ACTUALLY.
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF EVIL
IN THE WORLD, AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
THERE IS EVIL -- I DON'T CARE IF
IT IS A BROAD OR DOMESTIC, WE
HAVE ENEMIES TO DOMESTIC AND
FOREIGN.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
MY MAJOR CONCERN IN ALL OF THIS
IS HORWITZ ALREADY REFERRED, YOU
KNOW, FROM FURTHER
INVESTIGATION, McCABE AND
COMEY FOR LYING.
DIDN'T MICHAEL COHEN,
PAUL MANAFORT RECENTLY
ROGER STONE RUN INTO ISSUES
INVOLVING LACK OF CANDOR THAT
LED TO GUILTY ADMISSIONS,
CONVICTIONS?
>> YES, SO HE REFERRED PEOPLE
FOR PROSECUTION, COMEY, THEY
DECIDED NOT TO PROSECUTE BASED
ON WHAT THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
I TRUST WILLIAM BARR TO BE FAIR
TOO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS IN THE
REPORT, BUT HERE'S WHAT I
BELIEVE.
IF THERE WAS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THERE WAS CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE TO OPEN THE
INVESTIGATION, WHY DID THEY NOT
TELL TRUMP?
WHEN DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAD
SOMEBODY IN THEIR OFFICE THEY
BELIEVED TO WORK FOR COMMUNIST
CHINA, THEY TOLD DIANE, AND SHE
FIRED THE PERSON CARED IF THEY
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN AND
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANT
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANE
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANY
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN AND
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANN
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANT
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANL
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANE
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANC
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANM
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANA
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANG
ARE INVESTIGATING A CAMPAIGN ANN
ABOUT THE FOREIGN INFLUENCE,
THAN THAT TRULY IS FINE.
>> Sean: HERE IS WHAT I HAVE
BEEN TOLD BEFORE THE SHOW, AND
THIS IS WHAT I WAS TOLD NUMEROUS
TIMES, THAT THE FACTS THAT THE
IG WILL PUT BEFORE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL SHOCK THE
CONSCIENCE.
THEY WILL BE DEVASTATING TOO
MANY PEOPLE.
BUT IT WILL BE UP TO THE BAR AND
DURHAM.
IT WILL BE UP TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL --
>> 100%.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
DURHAM AND HIS REPORT.
AN CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE, WHICH BY
THE WAY, NO INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS THE ABILITY TO CONVENE A
GRAND JURY, MAKE CHARGES AND
PROSECUTE, DO THEY?
>> EXACTLY, HE IS NOT A
PROSECUTOR.
HE IS LOOKING TO FIND OUT IF THE
SYSTEM GOT OFF THE RAILS.
HOW TO PROTECT OR CHANGE IT IN
THE FUTURE, HOW TO MAKE SURE IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
THE BEST WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FISA COURT IS NOT DEFRAUDED
IN THE FUTURE IS TO HOLD THOSE
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE WHO ACTUALLY
DID THIS.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION, IS IT
THEN FAIR TO SAY THAT THERE WILL
BE A MAP THAT WILL BE LAID OUT
BY HORWITZ FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, FOUR DURHAM,
AND THEY WILL ALSO -- BY THE
WAY, WE ARE TOLD THAT THEIR
INVESTIGATION IS FAR MORE
ADVANCED THAN ANYBODY KNEW IT
THIS POINT.
>> THAT IS A GOOD WAY TO LOOK AT
IT.
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT THIS
INVESTIGATION A SORT OF A ROAD
MAP OF WHERE YOU MIGHT GO
CRIMINALLY.
>> Sean: WHATEVER DIFFERENCES
THERE ARE, I GUESS THE PERSON
THAT DECIDES WILL BE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WILL BE MR. DURHAM MR. MARK >>
IF THEY ARE INVESTIGATING MY
CAMPAIGN AND THEY THINK THAT SOM
CAMPAIGN AND THEY THINK THAT SOT
CAMPAIGN AND THEY THINK THAT SOI
CAMPAIGN AND THEY THINK THAT SOG
ON MY CAMPAIGN IS INFLUENCED BY
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, AND THEY D
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, AND THEY N
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, AND THEY T
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, AND THEY L
ME, AND THEY KEEP SPYING ON MY
CAMPAIGN, I WOULD BE REALLY
PISSED.
EVERY POLITICIAN IN AMERICA
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
IF, IN FACT, THEY OPEN UP A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THEY NEVER TOLD HIM
ABOUT IT, THAN THAT TRULY IS
SPYING.
AND EVERY POLITICIAN IN AMERICA
SHOULD BE WORRIED.
>> Sean: LAST POINT,
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION HAS TO START WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OBAMA.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.